always this gendern and the chocolate kisses
I can not call it that either
as I actually want to call them
what else can i say
and all this
only because of this left-green identity policy
okay we hear these accusations more often here
but what is actually this identity policy
identity policy describes movements
who stand up for the
their rights and possibilities
because of their identity
are threatened or diminished
as a feminist,
i am committed to this,
for example
that secure access to schwangerschaftsabbr s
is granted yes but that is exactly the problem
identity politics puts us all in drawers
we should not actually be working on it
that we are all really the same
yes of course in a perfect world the goal is
that all are treated equally
but to achieve this
we must first recognize
that this is not yet the case
and that we also do not all have the same life
have reality or problems
hey now let's be honest
everyone is doing well here in germany
no one experiences real discrimination anymore
everything was much worse in the past
unfortunately it is not better that simple
does not mean good
in addition,
those affected can decide much better
how big the problem is as an outsider
okay the two have there so
completely different points of view
how do you see the identity policy
yes or no write this down here